a new
submarine-launched ballistic missile
unveiled at a military parade in
pyongyang
further evidence that north korea
continues to develop nuclear weapons
and the missiles that could deliver them
this despite the trump administration's
focus on north korea
which amounted to a most unusual
four-year diplomatic
rollercoaster ride this was september
2017
at the un general assembly the united
states has
great strength and patience but if it is
forced to defend itself or its allies
we will have no choice but to totally
destroy north korea
yet only nine months later all had
changed
a historic meeting in singapore between
trump
and kim jong-un after a thor mainly
engineered by
south korea there was a clear rapport
between the two leaders
and we have developed a very special
fund
which led to a second meeting in 2019 in
hanoi though
the u.s wouldn't give ground on
sanctions we're discussing everything
and north korea wouldn't agree to give
up its nuclear arsenal
despite this trump while at the g20
summit in japan later in the year
suggested on twitter he took a detour on
the way home
the two met again in the demilitarized
zone
trump becoming the first u.s president
to set foot
in north korea
experts believe after all that the
mercurial north korean leader
will be skeptical about future diplomacy
i think he will be
much more cautious going forward which
is not necessarily good for
usdprk negotiations and i think you know
the price of everything has gone up as
well because
his skepticism that the relationship can
actually
change and that a different outcome is
possible the skepticism is starting to
raise
for the biden administration there are
no easy answers
on north korea they say they're going to
work more closely
with their allies in the region that
approach will help but it doesn't solve
the underlying problem which is getting
more acute by the day
and that's that north korea with time is
expanding its nuclear programme
james bays al jazeera washington